la tienda local de abarrotes abre a las
nueve su estacionamiento tiene seis
filas en cada fila caben siete carros
cada carro tiene cuatro ruedas cuántos
carros caben en el estacionamiento los
ánimos que pasa en el vídeo que piensen
en esto y traten de responderlo por
ustedes mismos
vamos a volver a leer esto la tienda
local de abarrotes abre a las nueve
bueno eso realmente no importa para
poder responder cuántos carros caben en
el estacionamiento tampoco es importante
saber cuántas ruedas tiene cada carro no
nos preguntan cuántas ruedas caben en el
estacionamiento así que podemos ignorar
esto lo que realmente importa es cuantas
filas tenemos y cuántos carros caben en
cada fila entonces tenemos seis filas
seis filas y en cada fila caben siete
carros por lo que tenemos seis grupos de
siete otra manera de pensar en esto es
seis por siete carros son los que caben
en el estacionamiento y esto que va a
ser igual
bueno literalmente es igual a sumar
siete seis veces es lo mismo que sumar
siete 12
3 4 5 6 esto lo tenemos que sumar
77 es 14 21 28 35 42 6 x 7 es igual a 42
en el estacionamiento cabe en 42 carros
no me creen hice un diagrama aquí para
que lo vean tenemos seis filas esta es
la primera fila segunda tercera cuarta
quinta sexta a cada fila le caben siete
carros uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
entonces cuántos carros tenemos aquí 7
14 21 28 35 42 42 carros en total 6
filas con 7 carros